NANDINI STOCKER: Hi, I'm Nandini
from Google's Conversation
Design Team, here to
give you some tips on how
to design your
own voice and chat
UIs using Actions on Google.
Before we dive in, let's
have a conversation
about conversation.
Consider this.
All human inventions
start as ideas.
By definition, conversation
is the exchange
of ideas by spoken words.
And by definition, civilization
is the most advanced stage
of human social development.
It's the tangible expression
of our common understanding
and values, which is
expressed through language.
And language is molded and
refined by conversations.
A conversation is a contract
between two participants
with a mutual investment
in the outcome.
But all of that is
really hard to codify.
Building natural
human-to-computer conversations
is hard.
But that's because
human-to-human conversations
are only deceptively easy.
People are not
going to change how
they converse any time soon.
So the key to closing that
gap between modern interfaces
and thousands of
years of evolution
is to use what we know to
be true about human-to-human
conversation to teach our
computers to talk to humans,
and not the other way around.
So the key to building
a good voice interface
is not to fall into the
trap of simply converting
a GUI into a VUI.
Obviously, I can't teach you
an entire design discipline
in a few minutes.
But I can give you five protips
to set you up for success.
Let's design a simple number
guessing game along the way.
Here we go.
Number one, leverage your brand
and give yourself a persona.
I don't mean a caricature
or mascot necessarily,
but you can do that too to
make it even more accessible.
A persona is more than that.
It's the consistent character
captured by the voice
and interactive experience.
It's the face of that
experience for the user.
First, list the core
attributes of your brand
and what you stand for.
Come up with the
corresponding attributes
that can be conveyed through
design elements and, of course,
the voice dialogue itself.
For example, if your brand
is known for speed, something
we at Google are known for,
some attributes of the design
might be to be intuitive
and data-driven,
since both of those elements
cut out steps for the user.
Some voice attributes for
the actual dialogue wording
might be engaging, or apt, or
approachable, since those also
tighten up the dialog by
removing ambiguity or making
it easier for the user to have
confidence in the interaction.
Write a short style
guide covering things
like pace, tone, energy
level, vocal attributes,
and the overall impression
that you're shooting for.
Try to create a simple biosketch
of a character that might
embody all of these attributes.
Give it a name, if you want.
Also, there's a practical reason
for creating a persona as well.
It's a good grounding
mechanism for you long-term.
Designers and developers
will come and go,
or multiple people could
work on it at once.
It'll give everyone something
to fall back on for consistency.
Finally, don't forget
to identify yourself
as a separate entity from
the Google Assistant.
That means greet the user.
Number two, think outside
the box, literally.
It's tempting to draw out a
conversation path visually,
and plug in the dialog, and
then dive right into the code
or start stringing
together blocks of context
to write a working agent, and
then back into the experience
iteratively.
We don't recommend this.
You can, but I promise you it
will save time and give you
a much richer experience to
map out the core conversation
paths ahead of time.
This doesn't mean just
the so-called happy path.
It doesn't mean
error paths either.
Instead, write out
your core experiences
like you would a screenplay.
This can be as scrappy as
acting it out and documenting it
on paper or create an
interactive prototype
you tweak and play with until
you're ready to start coding.
And then, when you draw
out your initial vision,
keep it at a high level,
where the boxes present
entire dialogs or user
intents, but leave out
the individual wording you'll
use in the interaction.
Number three.
Context.
Here are just some
types of context
you can consider and
infuse into a conversation
to make it more meaningful.
Where's the user?
What are they doing?
What type of device are
they interacting on?
How was the experience
influenced over time?
Where is the user's
frame of mind in relation
to what they're trying to do?
Try to cater to their intent,
not to a specific feature.
Number four.
Speech recognition
technology isn't perfect,
but it's getting
better all the time.
So for the most
part, you might want
to treat that as a black box
that will continue to improve.
You have to, of course, be
aware of its limitations,
but try to step back and
look at the interaction
from the user's perspective
when something goes wrong.
You don't have to try
to steer the user back
to the original
question if they don't
get recognized immediately.
There are so many reasons
they might not have been.
People hardly ever say nonsense.
Try to take those
so-called errors
and make them into another
meaningful turn in the dialog.
Finally, I leave you
with a challenge.
This new world of conversation
designed for machines
opens up a great
deal of opportunity
that hasn't existed before
for us to use technology
to advance our lives.
Sure, as you get started,
create some games.
But I urge you to think
bigger eventually.
Help give someone access to
information or technology
that they couldn't use before
because of a physical, mental,
or an economic disadvantage.
We're excited to help you do
that with Actions on Google.
Check out the description
for some resources.
And we can't wait to
see what you create.
[MUSIC PLAYING]